hi everyone my name is Tamra chambers
and this is Tamra's never seen and today
I am watching Independence Day for the
first time ever I have had this on my
list for ever we're nearing three years
of Tamra's never seen here where it's
coming up in the next month my name is
Tamara chambers and I'm about to watch
Return to Oz for the first time ever
it's gonna be so much fun which is
absolutely unbelievable
but this has been on my list since the
very start at least since my second
episode when I did Jurassic Park and I
loved Jeff Goldblum in it life finds a
way by the way I really watched that
movie quite a few times since my second
episode of me doing Jurassic Park and it
is such a good movie and I don't know if
I would have even seen it yet if it
wasn't for this show so that's really
cool I know it's about aliens
I know Will Smith says welcome to Earth
at some point and that's all you need in
a film I think I feel like so let's get
into it Wonder
[Music]
yeah that's what I imagined it was gonna
be a little longer than I imagined it
was gonna be but that's pretty much what
I imagined and I liked it it's insanely
dated and I also feel like if I would
have seen it at the time I would have
just fallen in love with it watching it
now I still was super entertained I just
I personally think they could have cut
off 30 minutes from this movie 45
minutes from this movie and it still
would have been just as good probably
better it's to nap hours but there were
moments where it felt like it was to nap
hours I think that's become my new
mantra in life is just movies shouldn't
be longer than two hours there's only a
few exceptions on that Shawshank
Redemption
I guess the Green Mile - Wow same
director visionary
oh and endgame for sure despite its long
time and it's dated Ness some of them
practicals didn't look too good the CGI
didn't look too good
the script was so 90s in a hilarious way
that like dated it but still me it was
fun to watch it for sure I felt like I
was transported back to the night I also
love Will Smith there haven't been many
Will Smith projects and I've been super
excited about recently I am seeing
Aladdin next week I'm a little nervous
I'm going in optimistic because I love
that character I love that movie and I
just am a little nervous because the
live actions aren't really my thing but
so anyways Will Smith hasn't been doing
that much recently like in like years I
feel like the last few things I really
really loved him and were inflicted
Pursuit of Happyness
and seven pounds
I thought he was really good in Suicide
Squad I think him and Harley definitely
were the best I think the characters
overall worked anyways we're getting
into a lot of other movies but Will
Smith I love him and he completely
carried this movie this film would have
been not nearly as good without Will
Smith I feel like I really like the
president character in this he seems
very down to earth and very self-aware
one of the first ones that he has is
isn't it interesting how quickly people
can turn against Pierre fetches the ring
is so true today I was just reading an
article about canceled culture so then
you meet David who is Jeff Goldblum's
character and he was preaching the good
word about anti styrofoam use in the 90s
his character is very eco friendly and
trying to save the earth wouldn't you
know it he gets to save the earth like
literally not just by recycling cans
which he should do but he can save the
world from aliens it's like a quicker
way to do it you're meeting a lot of
characters at this point the beginning
they're just throwing characters at you
you get the drunk pilot don't drink and
pilot a plane I said it wasn't to the
thousand times he's very much reminds me
of the aliens guy talking about being
abducted by aliens
it's all this very 90s because then we
get Will Smith and his girlfriend and
she goes out to get the mail and
everyone is like vacating their homes
and Will Smith realizes that something's
happening and he's looking around like
what well what do we do and his
girlfriend runs out like you want some
of this coffee so 90s
I would never chase a significant other
outdoors to ask if they wanted coffee
and just gonna wait until you come back
in I'm sorry
I'm sorry it's not that intense to
neither is anyone I feel like the first
half of this movie is so quick and
interesting and fast and then things
will really slow down as we go into the
second portion of this movie and then
the end of course quick and fast paced
again but a lot but like middle portion
we could have cut out there's a lot of
Jeff Goldblum explaining the science of
what he's doing and it's so funny
because none of it actual size which
that movie TV science well you know the
you know molecular biology if this goes
into the fallopian tubes of that and
then we get you know there's a cold for
the aliens Jeff Goldblum can jump but
it's revocable fry guy who is he does he
still have a voice today just terrible
vocal fry I would know is what I'm doing
right now it's vocal fry like as Vicki
is howling a bit Oh Jeb Pablo duck a low
voice actor
oh he was Edna hairspray that makes
sense
how does he still have a booming I was
very uncomfortable watching his scenes
because I was like his voice is gonna
die at any point any moment now any time
I've ever gone to a vocal coach in my
whole life they're like you have so much
vocal fry' jamming are you talk in the
back of your throat versus like up here
I'm supposed to be talking up here this
is where I should have my placement and
then I die you know I talk like this one
thing that I have to point out that no
no no film no TV show nothing ever ever
has captured before and that's the dog
jumping with an explosion behind him and
living that scene made everything so
much better
that's like Will Smith is flying around
and there's green alien lasers coming
out and he's going through like these
valleys of rock and desert it's like
super sad Star Wars Will Smith then
punches an alien in the head which is a
big mood welcome to earth I could have
been in a barbecue some really just
classic cinematic lines
Jeff Goldblum who's this scientist is in
Air Force one with the president they're
trying to brainstorm and figure out
what's happening and he's like don't you
guys know anything about aliens and the
president's like no whatever you've
heard is not true there's no aliens that
we've known about up until now and this
asshole in the back you go to area 51
we've got this ethnic music playing and
you walk in you see lo the aliens the
Aeneid ship and it's it's it's fun but
also the President must be like such an
idiot what's the point of being
president if you don't get those juicy
secrets it's just not worth being
president if you don't get to know about
feelings it's the one good thing about
being president you get to know about it
thank you for coming this has been my
TED Talks we'll meet up with the
presidents and Jeff Goldblum by
happenstance with the alien undertow and
he thinks that his girlfriend and son
are dead and the dog he missed the dog
explosion that sucks then we go to
Jasmine his girlfriend and and her son
and they think that will is dead it's a
classic romeo-juliet situation kind of
chicken soup figure but so jeff goldblum
comes up with this idea to give the
alien
ship a cold that way their defenses will
be knocked down and then they can attack
them because they're pretty much as
frail as humans are and everyone is like
Oh a cold I was so stupid what an idiot
like that's the ridiculous plan like
they didn't just nuke the United States
with no effects oh I think we got
control jeff goldblum ha ha
stupid I wrote I love the wedding Will
Smith and jasmine get married that's
what I want I want a love story shoved
into an action film if you'da shaved 40
minutes off of this movie it would have
been perfect we will not go quietly into
the night we will not vanish without a
fight
great Ryan we're gonna live on we're
gonna survive today we're gonna
celebrate our Independence Day oh yeah
the president goes off and fights
because he's a fighter pilot he belongs
in the air and no one is fake nope but
you're the president the vice president
has already died no you can't go fight
these eight you we need you sir I know
my daughter just lost her mother so if I
go up there and I die well what are you
gonna do I'm a fighter pilot and I
belong in the air they upload a virus
onto the aliens ship apparently the
alien ship also uses Windows 98 I think
this might be the cheesie's movie I've
ever seen Jeff Goldblum Will Smith
escape the alien ship and it's just it's
cheese to the max honestly I loved it I
really think they should have cut out
like three minutes of it but it was
super fun boomer will live yeah we were
we'll live that's the best part of the
Ruby yes
you'll enjoy it for the dumb popcorn
action movie is yes but you'll likely
think that some of the special effects
don't hold up some not at all
yes also bill Pullman's presidential
speech is legend yes
dammit Tamara you could have been at a
barbecue yeah for you there's some good
presidential predictions I again will
put them in a bit yeah you'll wonder how
they could possibly make a sequel yeah
super fun popcorn flick I think you'll
enjoy it and wonder why Will Smith seems
to want to play boring uncharismatic
characters anymore yes Brian I went to
college with Brian you're gonna love
this shit out of it yeah Brian I did I
had such a good time with this movie I
just honestly I love Jeff Goldblum he
was fantastic in it and Harry Connick
jr. and the president Bill Pullman right
great I just it made me long for those
sweet in-depth funny deep if charismatic
insightful
what's the word I want to use characters
that Will Smith plays he's a youtuber
now will we want to collab did I get it
oh no I didn't get that text with him
okay well I'll just wait thank you so
much for watching I had such a good time
with this I'm glad that I finally
watched it was it long yes was it
amazing yes did humour live yeah I will
see you all next week with Leon the
professional because you've almost won
the poll and then we'll see if I ever do
take a girl you know what I mean thanks
for watching I'll see you guys soon
[Music]
[Applause]
you